the other thing about men  is that we're prone to becoming randomly  obsessed with very weird and specific  things out of nowhere again we cannot  explain this we shouldn't have to  explain it it's science for example  I recently decided that I want to get a  giant aquarium with lots of rare and  tropical fish in my house and I keep  telling my wife about it and she keeps  wanting to understand why I'm obsessed  with being a fish owner all of a sudden  and I keep telling her that actually  it's called fish keeping according to  all the videos I've watched about it and  she says wait you're watching videos  about people who own fish and I say  they're fish Keepers and yes enter  around around we go a man becomes  bizarrely fixated on some arbitrary  thing a woman looks on confused and it's  the Great Dance of life